I used about the best time to take my ivervectin and fed-bed dissolved. I had been trying to space my
dose about 12 hours apart, and you commented that it may be best to take the ivervectin and fed-bed
dissolved separately. So I tried to space them a few hours apart at that. Now I'm reading that I should
be taking these with food. My eating window is typically nude to seven. So should I take the protocol
at nude and at seven? Or should I ignore my eating window and just take a bit of food with these doses
that are approximately 12 hours apart? And do I still do the bulk of my eating in my seven-hour
window? Yeah. So it's hard. Do I think you should take fed-bed dissolved in ivervectin? First of all,
at the same time. Now maybe I commented that you should split them apart, but that was just an
option. So I don't know that you can't take them together. Like if I'm taking 50 milligrams of
ivervectin and 22 milligrams of fed-bed dissolved, could I literally swallow them at the same time?
I think so. I don't, you know, obviously I think it's better with all your supplements if you can split
them up a little bit. But we have to live in the real world, too. And you have to look at the benefit
of, you know, I take it, you're talking about an eating window, you're talking about time-restricted
eating or intermittent fasting that you're trying to stick to. Now I will say that sometimes people
that don't take that take fed-bed dissolved, at least at an empty stomach, can feel a little
yucky because it can maybe upset their tummy a little bit. I've had that happen. I also think that
fed-bed dissolved has been shown that it is better absorbed if you take it with a fat because it's
not water, real water soluble. It's more fat soluble drug. So yeah, you kind of got to weigh these
things out and what's going to be best for you. It sounds like you're taking the ivervectin and fed-bed
dissolved twice per day according to this question. So yeah, I would say you want to make sure you're
not feeling sick from the fed-bed dissolved or the ivervectin. So eating some food and maybe getting
some fat in your food for better absorption, that would be more important than your eating window.
So I think that's what I would do is I would eat something with your dosage.